[Music]
hello and welcome back to the road to
2000.
as always my name is caleb denby and i
will be your driver
on this journey uh today of course the
big exciting action going on in the
chess world
is over on chess 24 with the magnus
carlsen
invitational finals and of course
semi-finals
that just wrapped up so i wanted to take
a look at some games i really enjoyed
from this uh or the semifinals match i
believe the finals have yet to be played
of course the semifinals saw a little
bit of controversy when they first
got started between ding loren and
magnus carlson
ding of course having a very rough go of
it in these online events
as of late he did manage to qualify for
these finals though
and at least on the first day he was
giving magnus a run
for his money so let's jump into game
number
one i wanted to show here between
dingler and magnus carlson
i believe this was actually the first
game they played in their
first day of the semifinals and
it was in fact ding with the white
pieces to to lead it off
uh ding essayed e4 and magnus replied
with
c5 something he has been known to do
lately
magnus lately really leaning heavily
into these sicilian defenses seeing a
lot less e4
e5 than we used to out of the world
champion uh
in the past two years after this match
that he had with fabiano
he has very much switched to the
sicilian
and to my knowledge in classical chess
obviously it's been a while since they
played but this guy still remains
unbeaten
uh since i think before even the world
championship match
so turns out he can play more than one
opening who would have guessed
uh ding responds with knight f3 we see
d6
c takes or sorry d6 d4 c takes d4
knight takes knight f6 knight c3
and a6 entering the night or
variation now
ding loren plays the move f3 this is
sort of an alternate move order
that can allow you to arrive at the
english attack in many different cases
for example if e5 were played here
knight b3
uh bishop e6 for example bishop e3 is
pretty much the only move here
and then we are well within the english
attack
however in this game we see that after
f3 magnus chooses not to stick with the
nightdorf
instead playing the move e6 and while
uh you know this was still the night
earth move order these are more the
cheveningen
positions that magnus is playing a bit
more often
ding still responds with bishop e3 and
now we see
a pretty stunning move from the world
champion it is a move that has been
played in the past but it's definitely
an offbeat line so fans of the english
attack or people who
saw my last chess openings explained
video
will have some idea of what white is
trying to do
in this opening generally white is
playing on
the king's side the point of developing
these pieces in this manner
is to go for this move g4 and try to
launch some kind of attack
on the king's side with g4 g5 and
especially
bringing this f-pawn up as well to
support this attack
so in the night or very often
these days the topical thing to do is
after we develop all the pieces queen d2
you'll see black play the move h5 and
this is actually what i recommended in
the chess openings explained series and
the point here
is to play against white's idea of
playing g4
and make him find some slightly less
comfortable alternate variations
to apply some pressure to black here and
magnus
in his infinite wisdom has decided that
he wants to employ the same idea
uh from the chevening again rather than
go for
uh the normal stuff of just b5
first magnus includes this move h5
so i would like to ask the chat room to
pause for a second
the obvious uh upside to
uh playing h5 is that you are preventing
for the moment the move g4
but i want to ask the chat room what are
the actual downsides to the move
h5 with the exclusion
that you can just say it generally
weakens the king's side i'm talking
specifics why is h5 not always the most
comfortable move for black what are the
downsides here
see what you guys have in the chat room
for me
[Music]
and with my very limited
spanish-speaking knowledge
i see the diego is asking me how many
elo points i have
i am around 2200. so oscar ortiz
has a very good point here and that is
the g5 square in particular is the
relevant square
that is weakened by the move h5 yes it's
true that very often now black is going
to shy away from castling king's side
because it doesn't make as much sense
with this pawn launched out here
you would rather have this rook to back
it up and in case the h file ever opens
the rook would be well placed
so the king's side is generally weaker
as you can say
but the g5 square is going to be really
really relevant
the point being now you never have this
move h6
to kick a bishop off of g5 and so keep
an eye out for this bishop g5 idea
a little bit later on in the game why
does bishop g5 matter
well we'll see in any position where
this pawn eventually gets pushed to e5
the d5 square is going to be the crucial
crucial square for black to keep a hold
of
and if after bishop g5 you can't get rid
of this bishop
it's definitely going to loosen your
control of the d5 square
indirectly so believe it or not h5
indirectly is weakening the d5 square
not the most intuitive but that is sort
of the the linking
chain there h5 weakens g5
g5 is weak so bishop g5 is often good
this bishop
can attack this knight which then
loosens control of d5
so let's keep an eye on that a little
bit later in the game it doesn't make
sense to do it immediately because
magnus has played this e6 move rather
than e5 so d5 is still under control
so first off ding plays queen d2
preparing the queenside castle
we see bishop e7 from magnus natural
development queen side castles
and now magnus does in fact play this
move b5
now ding plays a pretty interesting move
it's a move
that is always pretty controversial in
these openings with white
generally the standard way of meeting
these ideas of b5
is you just sort of chill you play the
move king b1 you allow black to sort of
develop the pieces
and then you can even start to challenge
this b pawn with something like a4
or you can sort of go about your
business in other ways
something like bishop d3 start playing
for f4
and other ideas like this
in ding's game though he responds to b5
in a little bit of a different
manner and i think the reason he
responds like this
is directly because of magnus carlsen's
h5
the move that ding chooses to play is
the move a3
and i think this is a a pretty deep idea
from ding the point is obviously that he
wants to slow down
the move b4 now why does he want to slow
down the move b4
well a lot of it uh
well first of all slowing down b4 is
usually just a good idea right b4 is a
huge source of counter play for black if
you can slow it down that's great
however a3 often isn't the best choice
for doing this
because it very much does weaken white's
queen side
there's uh ideas of sacrificing pieces
on a3
there's also ideas of when this pawn
does getting does get in
to b4 it will have the opportunity to
immediately open files with something
like b
takes a3 uh also getting time on the
night
things of this nature so a3 often isn't
the best idea for white here
but for the moment it does temporarily
slow down b4
b4 might be more effective if it gets
played in the game
but it is very much slowed down
so because uh dingleran has managed to
slow down b4
he won't have to move this knight as
quickly
that means that this knight can stay on
c3 and pressure the d5 square
once again it comes back to the square
of
d5 in the game um
now is this the only reason why ding
played a3 and do i know this for a fact
this is why ding played a3 no but it
does make logical sense
right magnus is weakened d5 with h5
so ding is playing for more pressure on
this square
and now magnus plays a move that i'm
going to call a little bit
of a mistake generally the standard way
of developing
is with bishop b7 here something like
king b1
and black can think about playing d5 in
many cases can think about playing e5
as well in some cases usually you want
to do something about knight f5 first
or just developing with knight bd7 and
coming out to the queen's side
with some some counter play in the game
uh magnus carlsen chooses to play the
move bishop d7
and while this bishop does provide some
good support
to the b pawn also keeping an eye on the
e6 pawn
and indirectly the f5 square keeping
everything sort of solidly together
obviously you're starting to notice the
pattern here it's neglecting control of
the d5
square ding loren still very chill
plays the move king b1 always a good
improving move in these positions
for white definitely makes sense to get
off this open c
file and control some of these squares
over on the a
file if anything bad were to ever happen
uh knight c6 comes on the board and ding
actually just trades off these
these knights and draws the black bishop
out
to c6 and now
unfortunately for magnus he was faced
with a pretty tough decision here
ding loren in
the opening has managed to apply quite a
bit of pressure
to the d6 pawn and now after bishop f4
magnus has to uh you know solve
this issue there's simply no way for
black to continue
defending this d6 pawn and so there are
two ways
to solve this problem number one you
move it out of the way
play pawn to d5 number two you move
this pawn up with pawn to e5
so thus far i've talked about uh i've
talked a lot about d5 control
but i don't think magnus carlsen is out
of the game just yet it's not like he
did a ton of things horribly wrong
he just chose some specific lines that
did
loosen his control of d5 it's not as if
white should be winning here
by any means but black does need to be
cautious
he needs to be aware of
his opening choices here so chatroom
what do you think e5 or d5
what is the way to go for black
what is the way to go you have to solve
this issue of your d-pawn somehow
a couple people in the chat room say e5
is the thing to do
and quaffly says d5 so
with d5 you have to be very very careful
you have to
make sure you're calculating accurately
make sure you're not missing anything
because this is the move that adds more
tension to the center that means white
is going to have options to open the
center
options to keep the center closed
options to just keep the tension
and play some improving move whereas e5
is a bit more forcing
but in fact d5 is the correct way to go
in
this particular instance and the reason
is there's no good way
for white to immediately open things up
this isn't actually achieving much this
queen on d8
is defended well enough for the moment
and if white tries to
take advantage of this pin the simplest
option
for black is probably something just
like queen c8 you can immediately step
out of the pen
and there's no chance to play a move
like c4
to break open the d file and as far as
how could play continue well sometimes
you'll see this king actually come out
this way
sometimes you'll see this king castle
but black should be doing
okay in this position now in the game
magnus actually chose to play the move
e5 and i definitely think
this was where ding solidly grabbed the
advantage now after e5 you probably
guessed that the move bishop g5 might be
coming
and now uh already
white is starting to to take over the d5
square and this is sort of the
the main issue here for black there's
nothing he can do
to keep control of d5 in the game he
played the move queen b6
we see white trade off these dark square
this dark squared bishop
for the knight controlling d5 now after
knight d5
we have takes takes and the problem on
d6
is not going away white has seized
control
of the d5 square and in doing so he's
also traded off
all but one set of minor pieces
uh the minor pieces that are left are
this light squared bishop
for white and this dark squared bishop
for black
and neither of these pieces were either
side's you know favorite pieces in the
position of course
white's dark squared bishop was a very
powerful piece that he had to give up
for this
black's knights over on
sorry f6 forgot where it was over on f6
was doing a great job of defending d5
defending the king side
but these are the pieces left remaining
so
what is going on here uh obviously
i've sort of already given away the fact
that i think white is doing very well
but i want to ask you guys why why is
white
doing so well here and i'll give you a
hint
part of it is yes due to this massive
control over the d
file but i want to talk a little bit
about these bishops
so what about the bishops makes this
this position
so good for white
what about the bishops is it in
particular
that are giving white somewhat of an
advantage here
all right you guys are offering up uh
some general ideas
saying white's bishop is better but
that's not what i'm uh
not what i'm asking here i'm sort of
hinting that white's bishop is better
and that's why his position is better
but what makes white's bishop good in
this position
there's a couple things in particular
because if you look for the moment right
this bishop's sort of locked in by these
pawns can't really go anywhere
it's also locked in by its own pawns on
the king's side black's bishop is
facing a similar similar story but you
know g5
is an open square maybe this bishop can
can get active
so yeah you guys are arriving at the
idea uh
now and the point is this bishop for the
moment
is hemmed in by these pawns but after
the key breaks
c4 this bishop is actually going to
become very very active
you can imagine if this bishop lands on
c4 challenging the f7 pawn
challenging the queen's side it's going
to be a very active piece
in the meantime let's say after king e7
played in the game to defend the pawn
in the meantime black is going to have a
much more difficult uh
job in trying to activate his dark
squared bishop
now in the game dean loren actually
plays c4 immediately which is a great
plan to open up the bishop as i said but
there's actually another move here
that makes a lot of sense for white and
it's in the same vein
the same vein of thinking so like i said
maybe bishop g5
and coming over to these sorts of
squares is one day
an active plan for black and so the move
h4
is actually interesting to consider as
well the idea being
you are locking black out of this square
for the moment and locking this pawn on
a square where it could later be
targeted but
i do like c4 a bit better just wanted to
mention this idea
of not only activating your own pieces
but keeping your opponent's pieces
inactive it's usually a fantastic idea
so c4 is played in the game
and b takes c4 is actually just going to
be
uh sort of suicidal for black
of course there's no way to really deal
with this
and then the major pieces are going to
start coming in
for uh for white for sure so
c uh b take c is sort of ridiculous you
can't
really get away with playing the move b4
either the move c5 is going to come
and pretty nasty stuff here
or alternatively this and then
i don't see the the immediate tactic but
maybe just
just threatening the the checkmate like
this is good enough
obviously not the most comfortable spot
here for uh
for black some checkmates
some trackmates in the air just some
so b4 not playable b takes c4
not playable magnus chose to move rook a
to c8s
and now dingler n can simply win this
pawn
on b5 uh
sorry this wasn't played in the game uh
c takes b5 was played in the game
dingler n or sorry magnus carlson's idea
was to play rook c5 here
but after queen b3 can't take this with
the major piece because the bishop
defends
we have a4 sorry a takes b5 and then a4
taking advantage of the pin on the pawn
if you try to play the move
b4 we've seen this story before no
matter which piece is in front
this battery against f7 is still going
to be rather devastating with bishop
takes f7 being a humongous threat
rook f8 is just a little bit too passive
now
for uh for black as white is going to be
able to utilize
both rooks on the queen side while black
will have to keep
one rook behind to defend
and so uh in the game magnus just gives
up on the pawn on b5
we see bishop takes b5 and now black
does
finally manage to activate this piece
rook d3 though
keeps it out of the game for the moment
rook c1 check would not
achieve much here just king up to a2
and at the end of the day it's uh it's
just ding loren
with an extra pawn and in fact it almost
feels like
two extra pawns as these two pawns on
the queen side are passed and connected
and their counterpart is on d6 which is
always a sad pawn
in these positions for black
in the game ding had some very good
technique plays the move rook d1
we do see rook c1 check rick takes d1
rick takes d1
the bishop comes up to f4 ding happily
plays the move
h3 uh we see bishop e3
like i said this bishop does get active
eventually but
it's not enough in this case bishop c4
finally arrives on the board
this sort of lurking threat that has
been
uh narrowly avoided by magnus for the
past 10 turns
now queen b3 and sorry not bishop but
king takes b3
and bishop d4 rook d2 f5
rook c2 takes takes king f6 played in
the game
bishop b5 rook b8 king b4
king g5 and then the technique here is
simply a matter of
pushing these pawns up the board it is
not the most
difficult win in the world once again
black's only
uh extra pawn quote-unquote anywhere on
the board is on d6 and it's not going to
be useful
in this case so ding goes on to win
quite easily a5 throws in rookie 2 to
defend this guy
a6 whenever possible i ship c5 check
king a5
bishop a7 b3 sort of a waiting move
allowing this rook to
participate over on the queen side
also granting this bishop the c4 square
zero k1 check
king b5 b1 king c6 bishop c5 king b7
rook a1 and then after b4 magnus had
seen enough uh very smooth victory
for ding loren here uh i really do think
that
this is the game to highlight the d5
square in all of these sicilian
positions
where e5 is ever potentially playable
um in this game magnus lost control of
d5
ding loren played a very excellent game
and went on
to win using this control getting this
favorable position of the bishops
magnus carlson and ding loren ding
jumping out to an early lead
but then magnus being the world champion
had the white pieces in game two and
this is something that you'll see magnus
carlsen do
uh quite a bit uh he'll lose one game
rarely very rarely but then when he does
he tends to win the next one uh he's
this is something that
i think a lot of the world's greatest
chess players throughout history have
sort of had a habit of doing
uh gary kasparov definitely comes to
mind if you were paired with gary
and you saw that he lost his last game
then i think the stories go that you
might as well just resign because scary
was not losing two in a row
and that's the case for magnus here he
came back with the white pieces and it
came back to win so let's see what
happened
in game two we have d4 knight f6
knight f3 and four everybody's favorite
opening the london system c5
e3 e6 c3 and we are well
uh in the clutches of the london
bishop d6 is the natural move by ding
loren
or bishop g3 not allowing e takes f4
weakening the d4 pawn
slightly in the game though magnus says
nah i'll have none of that
and just plays the move knight b to d2
and this is a pretty interesting
decision uh right now
black has the option to go for this
imbalance
and i wanted to talk just a little bit
about this
pawn structure because it's a pretty
interesting one
likely magnus's follow-up after c takes
d4 isn't to take back with the pawn
but to take back with the knight and so
the question is
what exactly is going on in this
position
well black has two central pawns and so
at first glance
you might say that black has an
advantage in the center
however because white does not have any
central pawns but is controlling them
with uh but is controlling the center
with pawns from the outside
it might turn out to be a case where
white can actually occupy the center
with his pieces
which would be pretty advantageous
compared to occupying it with
the pawns and this is an interesting
game
that we never got to see because this is
not what dingleran played
instead he chose the move c takes d4
which you know is is pretty natural
uh likely he assumed white would reply c
takes d4
e takes d4 is notably a move that is uh
now prevented due to white's play not
preserving this bishop with bishop g3 or
knight e5 or trading it off
now of course e takes d would hang the
bishop and after c takes d
uh the game would be you know reasonably
even
reasonably level then ding might
consider taking here
when white could no longer take on d4
with the knight having already captured
with the pawn
and here black might be very very happy
to apply some pressure to the slightly
weak
d4 pawn now magnus carlsen
had other intentions for this position
though
c takes d4 is an attempt at sort of
refuting
magnus's opening play not refuting in
the sense that black would be winning
but refuting in the sense that
magnus would have nothing to play for
really after the move c takes d4
this would be a very level position and
especially after bishop takes f4
it's black with the pressure on white's
center but
magnus being magnus was like nah i'll
take on d6 instead i'll have none of
that thank you
uh and ding could have just captured
back on d6 with the queen
but now e takes d4 would once again be
playable
and this is of course the fabled
carlsbad structure and here i do believe
magnus
might be ever so slightly better just
because this bishop
has not had all of its problems solved
yet black is gonna have to work pretty
hard
to to activate this guy here and
so ding loren uh instead plays the move
d takes e3
and this is magnus's idea he sacrifices
uh both of his center pawns in order to
take off the dark squared bishop
and preserve his dark squared bishop on
the very strong diagonal
on a3 currently preventing castling
uh ding manages to regain his piece with
e takes d2 we see queen takes d2
and now knight c6
um and now
we see uh an idea which you will
often see in either you know games
played by the world champion or 2800s
2700 level players
or you'll see it in a game between you
know like 400s 500s new players to chess
and that is the idea of the strong
attacking queen
go go queen go attack those pawns
those pawns are nothing and
so magnus very aggressively does play
this move queen
g5 and the idea is now
that magnus carlsen has sacrificed both
of his center pawns
what does he have in exchange well he
has control over the dark squares
and this idea is very very important
since magnus has sacrificed
so much i keep saying he sacrificed both
central pawns of course he's only
down one pawn here he got the c pawn in
return
but lacking both pawns in the center
does mean that if you play too slowly
black is sort of just going to uh to
roll over your position
in the center so no center pawns for
white
uh which is why it's so important that
magnus immediately starts taking control
of the dark squares and uses this to his
advantage because that is really
the only imbalance in white's favor here
his control over the dark squares
and that's why queen g5 makes so much
sense here you know it'd be great to
develop this bishop
but this isn't really going along with
magnus's plan of controlling the dark
squares
and in fact it does present black the
opportunity to play e5
and start regaining control of at least
some of those squares
right queen g5 move that prevents both
e5
pressures more dark squares on the
king's side and is
essentially baiting black into playing a
move like g6
when wow oh wow oh wow you'll never
control
any of these squares ever again if
you're playing with the black pieces
and that is a terrifying thought in the
game
ding chose a slightly better option than
g6 which is rook g8
uh but once again i just want to
highlight the idea here
magnus's idea isn't to launch some kind
of crazy attack with his queen from the
opening
that would be the idea of you know the
400s and the 500s that you see
do the crazy queen openings where they
attack you know anywhere on the board
magnus's idea is to take control of the
dark squares and that's exactly
how you need to play when you have
managed to trade off one of your
opponent's bishops
for one of your knights right you take
over the color square
that your opponent is lacking
okay rook g8 and magnus now simply
develops this last piece with bishop d3
we now see the move h6 and this is the
right idea once again from ding loren
uh he he is lacking the dark squared
bishop so to make up for it
he starts trying to control dark squares
with his pawns this is a good way to
compensate
when you are missing that bishop the
queen comes back to e3
and ding plays queen b6 note that the
entire story of this game now
is a game being fought on the dark
squares it's like these squares
they don't matter right neither player
is arguing
that these squares are good for black
magnus is
uh pretty much solely playing for
control of these dark squares
now trading off the queens would
obviously be in black's favor here as he
is
up like i said a full pawn and has two
extra center pawns
so queen e2 was played in the game uh
now dingler n plays bishop d7 trying to
get developed
we see white go ahead and castle and
black queen side castles
okay now what's next
for magnus carlson i would like to ask
you guys at home
to take a moment and find out uh
what you think magnus should be doing
next with his time here
how do you continue to fight even harder
for the dark squares in black's position
how do you fight for those dark squares
deep mind says maybe b3 and c4
and attack and there's a couple people
in the chat who say the move b4 what's
your idea
with the move b4 why play b4 here
why play the move b4
95 is also suggested
any other ideas
okay so let's talk about 95
so 95 i definitely think is actually a
leaving
some of the pressure for black
and the reason for that is you are
trading
this knight which controls dark squares
for this knight which also controls
dark squares so after 95 95
it's true that you removed a defender of
the dark squares
you also removed an attacker of the dark
squares though
and now the only pieces that white can
immediately utilize to attack on these
long open diagonals or weak
weak squares in the center are the queen
and the bishop
whereas he would rather much have uh
this
he would much rather have this knight
back on f3 to jump into e5 at a later
date
and that's exactly why i do believe b4
which magnus chose
is the best idea for white in the game
now why b4 nobody in the chat managed to
answer my question
well the point is not that you're
controlling these two squares more
the point is that you're angling to play
the move b5
and we'll see that's exactly what
happens in the game king b8
b5 and now we have in fact fought for
the dark squares
by removing this defender of the dark
squares without giving up
our own piece the move knight a5 was
played in the game
and now after knight e5 i think magnus
already has a very significant advantage
in the game black actually only had one
move
to maintain the balance in this case and
that move was to play e5
which is sort of counter-intuitive right
the idea is tactically it does work out
for black you can respond to b5 with the
move e4
and after takes on c6 you don't take on
d3 or
f3 when this would come with check but
you can take back on c6 yourself
and then let's see maybe with the bishop
is simpler
and then after something like knight d4
you get rid of these pieces
and now uh black has given up his extra
pawn
but because he's given up the pawn he
can find activity along the
e file as well as jump this knight into
nice squares like e4 at a later date
notably defending some loose dark
squares in his
position okay but e5
is not the most intuitive move and
honestly i still don't fully understand
why black is doing okay there against uh
some pretty powerful white pieces but we
will stick to the game
king b8 b5 played in the game which is a
great idea by magnus
knight a5 and now knight e5 and like i
said
magnus has sort of taken over uh
essentially half of the chess board
meaning all of the dark squares
on the board are starting to belong to
magnus carlsen
bishop e8 played in the game had to
defend f7 somehow
and now bishop b4 and this is what i
mean by
all the dark squares magnus is not even
content to allow this knights on
a5 to rest peacefully black is going to
have to work to keep a piece on a dark
square keeping this piece defended at
all times
we see the move rook to c8 and now
magnus
magnus's other idea with bishop b4 is to
bring the a pawn forward
out to a4 to go ahead and support this
b5 pawn
knight e4 is ding loren's choice in the
game
and this is sort of the final blunder of
the
of the game here this one really does
allow magnus to win the position
quite easily uh maybe better for ding
was to retreat this queen back with the
idea
of after maybe back to c7
and the idea is to bring this knight out
to e4
a little bit later on and have a little
bit more control
on this seventh rank but let's just see
why 94 loses the game
knight e4 magnus simply takes takes
takes
and now there are a
myriad of threats if you stop the move
queen h7
then white simply takes over in the
center with something like rook f to d1
this bishop can't move rook d6 is coming
for example f6 rook d6
takes here things are just sort of
collapsing bishop d6
is the threat and so in the game we saw
f6
immediately but now of course queen h7
was not prevented
and there's no comfortable way to defend
this rook if you move this bishop
bam knight d7 is awkward
if you take on e5 it just takes on g8
and life is not getting better for ding
in the game you played knight b3 magnus
took on g8
takes on e1 and then the final move of
the game
queen takes e8 with knight d7 to follow
was enough
for ding loren to give this one up
uh so really incredible game here by
magnus shows exactly how to play
against a missing bishop in your
opponent's position
you just aim to take over half of their
squares
all of the dark squares in this game
belonging to magnus and that is what
allowed him
to win the game with very active pieces
okay any questions on this one in
particular
and then we'll move on to one or two
games by the other semi-finalists
of course daniel dubov and hikaru
nakamura
i do want to mention that while ding
did lose this game on the first day he
actually went on i believe to win
day one in armageddon against magnus and
then magnus unfortunately for dink
did come back to win the next three days
to advance on to the finals
all right let's go ahead and move on
then i did want to start with
one of dubov's only wins against
nakamura naka played
very very well against dubov in their
semi-final matchups
and i believe won all three days of
their match
to advance to the finals but dubov had
one or two nice games and this was
definitely one of them
if you guys are a fan of miniatures this
one i believe qualifies
under most definitions but let's just
jump into it here see what happens
dubov plays d4 knight f6 c4
e6 knight c3 bishop b4 going for the
nimzo indian
and then we have knight f3 so a
uh three nights i believe it's called
rather than two nights
nimzo and this is a reasonably solid way
of playing against the nimzo
for white uh some of the more ambitious
lines
involve leaving this knight back on g1
queen c2 is the classical
uh nimzo indian to help defend this
knight on c3
i of course if you have been following
me for some time now
i am a huge fan of the f3 nimzo indian
challenging the e4 square directly e3
also a main move but knight f3 one of
the more solid
approaches we have king side castles by
black
and then bishop g5 by white
and the point here is that this bishop
has left the king's side by coming out
to b4
and so if we go bishop g5 maybe
this bishop would be better served on e7
in some cases
for black also notably if white or black
were to play something like
this we could still come out to bishop
g5
but in some of these cases black has
afforded a little bit more freedom to
sort of kick around this bishop with
stuff like h6 and g5 because he hasn't
yet committed to castling
for example h6 bishop h4 and g5 is
already
a pretty well known line knight e4 to
follow
and we can take advantage of some of the
awkwardness of white's pieces
but uh hikaru simply castles now bishop
g5
and black is a lot less comfortable
playing h6 and g5 when his king is
sitting here
on g8 so in the game simply c5 by hikaru
and rook to c1 by
and now h6 bishop h4 but naca isn't
planning to
follow this up with g5 in this case just
kicking this bishop off of the
g5 square where it had some options to
retreat along this diagonal
and now c takes d4 is the plan
for nakamura he wants to get rid of the
strong central d4 pawn
from white and we do see knight takes d4
now by black
or sorry by white and the nakamura
attempts to
sort of immediately equalize with the
move d5
and this is something that you actually
see a lot from
nakamura in the way he's playing against
1d4
he's very happy to go for a quick c5 and
then he will
pretty early on in the opening generally
try and solve all of his opening
problems
with a break like d5 now
uh the downside to this
is perhaps in some games perhaps in
particular
this game black was not yet ready to
break through
with d5 as far as other choices
knight c6 has been played with some
success
and following this up with d5 can be
quite good even bishop back to e7
playing the the position very very
slowly uh taking advantage
or breaking this pin uh even if it is at
the cost of a tempo
and nakamura himself i believe has
actually had this exact position against
levon ironian
but in this game he goes for d5
now what's the downside to playing d5
immediately well in
a perfect world this is how the game
would go we would have
c takes d5 we'd have something like
queen takes d5
and something like e3 knight e4
and black would have absolutely no
issues
in this case or it could be one for
example
and now the point is black has a very
compact pawn structure
white has no real advantages in the
center of the board and black can just
continue with natural development
with something like knight c6 now why
wasn't this
what happened in the game well naka was
likely a little bit uncomfortable about
white's option to play the move bishop
takes f6 here after queen d5
g takes f6 would be forced and now
black's king side is a little bit
fractured
and like i said this might not be
something that nakamura is quite happy
with he
is essentially trying to solve his
opening problems immediately
and with this fractured king side he
definitely still has some problems to
solve
the game might continue a3 if this
bishop moves back then the queen hangs
so knight c6 is now forced knight takes
c6
bishop takes c3 rook c3 in d1
king d1 bc6 and actually white
is already sort of winning a pawn or
is he maybe maybe he's winning a pawn
maybe it's better just to develop
rather than face some awkwardness
on the queen side but okay
obviously queen d5 not as simple as it
may seem because this bishop on h4 is
still challenging
this knight here so in the game
nakamura's idea was to
play the move g5 first not allowing
bishop takes f6
and then he was able to take back with
the knight
on d5 and this might actually be the
move
that gives white a little bit of an edge
and this position has been reached
actually well over 20 times
and uh a lot of those times by very high
level players
and queen takes d5 has been played in
every single game
the idea being after white tries to
develop naturally
black is able to get some very immediate
counter play on the queen side
to make up for his fractured kingside
structure not quite as bad as g takes f6
but h6 and g5
definitely leaves quite a number of
weaknesses over here
and so essentially in all these games
black is able to sort of leverage
this pressure on the queen side this
extra pawn for the moment
into some kind of queen trade or trading
off more pieces so that these weaknesses
on the king's side don't really matter
now in the game
naka plays knight takes d5 immediately
and without this active queen coming
into a2
unfortunately nakamura does not have the
activity required
to get some of those trades
some of those pieces off the board to
make up for the fact that he has
weakened his king's side
in the game dubov simply plays e3 and
now queen
a5 but queen a5
to a2 is not quite the same as
queen d5 to a2 as we shall soon see
bishop d3 played in the game and now
queen takes a2 would very readily
be met with castles when all of a sudden
you know black is is just simply
checkmated
you can compare this with the lion after
queen d5 e3
queen takes a2 here if bishop d3 were
played
now knight d5 would be the position we
just saw
but of course black can play queen takes
b2 and is that one tempo faster
that he absolutely needs to be able to
survive this position
so in the game queen a5 bishop d3 now
castles is a
huge threat and black is sort of simply
lost out of the opening already castles
is pretty difficult to stop
if you take on c3 white will recapture
back
if you take here queen d2 is actually a
rather annoying pin
that would win a full piece and so
and this knight might have to might have
to jump back to f6
and white has a few options not the
least of which
is to just play something like h4 or
even queen f3
followed by something like h4 and just
break open the king side
taking advantage of black's hubris in
the opening
uh in the game hikaru plays the move
rook d8
and dubov just castles and now
queen h5 is a massive massive threat and
in fact
knight takes c3 played in the game dubob
doesn't even bother
taking this piece back he says i will go
checkmate you now thank you very much
bishop f8 is forced to guard this guy if
he tried to save this uh guy here
everybody knows this checkmate queen h7
or actually yeah or if something like f5
just take here and everything is falling
apart
so queen h5 bishop f8 was played rook
takes c3 now regains the piece
e5 bishop c4 ouch queen c7
and bishop takes e5 and that was enough
for hikaru nakamura to resign this game
so probably naka just mixed up lines
with knight takes d5 and queen takes d5
and that ended up costing him a full
point in this case
i do want to mention though this was one
of the only full points that nakamura
lost
in the entirety of the three matches
that he played with duboff but i did
want to highlight this game
since dubaf had such a rough go of it
this time around let
us now move on to yet another game
between dubov and nakamura and this is
going to be one
that actually did end up going naka's
way
one of the many in this case
and we are actually going to see it
arise from a pretty similar opening
so let's check it out see what hikaru
did differently
in this case we have d4 knight f6
c4 e6 knight c3 bishop b4
knight f3 and again castles bishop g5
and c5 now this is where in the previous
game we actually saw
duboff play the move rook c1 c takes d4
knight takes d4
then we had this h6 bishop h4 and d5
and complications that naca ended up
messing up
however duboff likely suspected that
nakamura had checked his file since the
last game or just remembered
since the last game and so he chose not
to repeat
this variation instead he played a very
very combative move and that move
is d5 and now of course the position
starts to resemble uh benoni benoni
style positions uh there is one key
difference
from most bononi positions and that is
rather than this bishop being here
this bishop is here and so fans of the
snake bononi will know that the bishop
on b4 is actually
not such a bad piece for black compared
to the bishop back on g7
and black shouldn't be too unhappy about
having this guy
out here in my opinion uh d6
was naka's choice in the game and now e3
and this is sort of part of the
unfortunate uh
status of the white pieces because this
bishop is already here
on b4 white has to work a lot harder to
gain control over the e4 square
for example if e4 were played
immediately
perhaps some of the difficulty would
revolve around the immediate rook e8s
if you try bishop d3 be on the lookout
for knight takes e4 tactics
free queen but you lose your queen as
well
so e3 played instead by duboff
and now we see ed5 c takes d5 and knight
b
to d7 now after bishop d3
white does have the advantage of not
having this diagonal locked down
by the pawn on e4 but
white also lacks a lot of the uh threats
that you get from the mainline benonis
where this pawn
ends up on e4 very very quickly now we
do see
h6 by hikaru kicking this bishop away
once again
we do see the bishop coming back to h4
and then naka plays this move queen a5
you know
perhaps already you know getting rid of
those bad memories from the last game
when he played queen a5 and immediately
got checkmated
in this game he at least has the solace
of knowing that his king
side is not going to immediately get
destroyed
dubov castles out of this one and this
is in fact
just a pawn sacrifice by dubov
and i think this is about as good of a
pawn sacrifice
or sorry about as uh good of a pawn for
black as you can really hope for
in the bononi uh by getting rid of this
extra
b pawn that white has if black
can achieve something like b5 and c4
black is going to win on the queen side
like there's nothing
stopping black from just straight
winning on the queen side
and so what that does is it puts white
in a situation
where white had better do something uh
you know either to stop this
or on the king's side pretty quickly or
else
you know he's just going to get rolled
over and we'll see that in this case
dewbov actually was not able to uh to
add that kind
or to apply that kind of pressure to
black's position
perhaps his best try would have been to
play the immediate bishop g3 when you
can already see
that hey wait a second maybe this queen
is a little bit off sides here
not back on in the center on d8 on c7 to
guard this guy
the play might continue with something
like c4 or
knight takes d5
when black gives up his d-pawn but does
manage to capture
white's d-pawn uh and there is one game
here between la quang liam and
peter lecko that went bishop b5 knight 5
to f6
bishop takes d6 rook eight rook c1
queen back to a5 queen out to b3
queen b6 so black does have to take a
few
moves with this queen to get it back
into play and after rook f to d1
white isn't worse but white is much
better either
these bishops for the moment are looking
a little bit
uh dangerous but after a6 this bishop
actually has nothing better to do and
exchange it here
and we see more trades
on sorry knight takes d7 was played in
the game bishop c5
and this position is dead drawn
and so this is about as well as i think
it can actually go
for white instead though duboff plays
the move e4
and this is the more testing try rather
than go for these simplifications allow
black to take on d5
allow yourself to take on d6 do buff
plays e4 and says nah
i'm keeping my d5 pawn you do what you
want i
am going to try and win this game
rookie 8 is a natural move by black to
challenge the e4 pawn now
rookie 1 to support and now
hikaru plays a very very interesting
move and that move
is b5 so he's willing to give up his
b-pawn in exchange
for the e-pawn uh and this b5 move i
believe
is is a very very valuable uh move
by nakamura if this b-pawn is allowed to
live
then the move c4 is going to be coming
next and this bishop
is quickly going to run out of squares
this knight is going to
come in on those squares this knight as
well can come back to e5
and invade on d3 and black would just
have a very very excellent position
so with all of that in mind white
definitely
needs to do something about it before it
happens one option would have been play
the move a4 when now after c4 this
bishop just drops
back to c2 and b4 would be a bit too
much when after rook
e3 queen b2 rook b1 this pawn does end
up falling
one other option might be to actually
accept this trade
and drop this bishop into c6 excuse me
rook b8 for example bishop g3
and at the end of the day it's going to
be rather similar to
what we saw in that uh
laquan against our liam lay against
peter lecko game where this one is
likely going to fizzle out
but instead dana duboff plays rook c1
attacking the queen
but this queen was actually offsides on
c3 and acaro is very happy
to bring it over to a3 where it can sort
of indirectly
at least help this d-pawn out a little
bit and
stop a4 prepare c4 and prepare to kind
of just win this game
uh bishop b1 played in the game and i do
think c4
is pretty reasonable here for black
maybe though nicara was not yet ready to
give up the d4 square
to his opponent so he delays it for a
bit just plays knight g4
and reroutes this knight back to e5
knight d2
is attacking this guy knight b6 to
support the queen side play
and defend the knight we see h3 and now
95
and i do believe that i would much
rather
be black in this position than white all
the pressure
is sort of on white in this case and
that's the danger that you face
when you sacrifice such an important
pawn on the queen side
against the benoni queen h5 now played
in the game
and this turned out to be a pretty
crucial mistake knight b to c4
knight the knight comes over to b3 and
now a5
and like i said black is going to win
on the queen's side uh now maybe
dubov could have tried playing something
like f4 this knight would
retreat probably back to either d7 or g6
and something like e5 this is sort of
the the desperate attacking
uh play that white has to go for
already in in this case and you know
maybe it works out maybe it doesn't who
can really
tell it's going to be a complex attack
to be sure
but this is sort of what white already
has to go for if you don't break things
open immediately
black just wins and in the game we see
rook c3 was played
and exactly what i've been describing
did in fact happen queen b4 now
the rooks are sort of skewered the rook
comes over to c1
and knight g6 was played by naka
stepping out of f4 before it happens
bishop f6 was dubov's try perhaps asking
naka to capture here when queen takes a6
might offer a little bit
of uh danger to
to naka's king with ideas of this coming
uh instead though just a4 to attack the
knight
the rook comes to g3 but now rook e5
naca does not capture this bishop
fracturing his structure
in fact he offers up an exchange which
is accepted
but now this knight is actually
incredibly trapped
knight a1 would not be ideal queen b2
would actually attack three pieces at
the same time
and so knight takes c5 is played we do
see d takes c5
and naca has two pieces for the rook
and like i said is winning on the queen
side rook f1
queen d4 king h2
rook a6 f4 this rook comes over to f6
now
and it's sort of checkmate or bust for
dubov
unfortunately in this case it is bust as
we see him
launching those pawns forward on the
queen side without getting checkmated
just moving them forward step by step
and then
we do see dubov giving back the exchange
to avoid a queen trade
and once again these pawns are too
powerful
and duboff went ahead and resigned in
this position so
some really fun games uh from the finals
of the magnus carlsen
invitational here we see nakamura sort
of just
uh stampeding on the queen site to
defeat daniel
dubov in this particular game and i did
very much enjoy
the battles between magnus carlson and
ding loren
hopefully you enjoyed this edition of
the road 2000
be sure to stay tuned for the end game
class
where i'm going to teach you everything
you ever wanted to know
and ever didn't want to know about
playing with a rook
against a bishop in pure endgames so
stay tuned for that it's going to be a
fun one i think you guys are going to
enjoy it
but that's it for me here uh here
tonight on the road
2000. as always my name is caleb denby
and i will see you next time
you